[Applaudissements]
merci d'être avec nous les vacances on
est en direct et merci Raymond pour ton
coup de gueule au contraire qui était
très fort bravo mon chéri bravo mon
chéri et c'était très bien que tu le
dises
l'info la plus commentée du jour c'est
jeune homme qui a été filmé en train de
manger une souris vivante lors d'une
soirée étudiante décidément oui sachez
que Mickey a porté plainte
vous avez bien entendu ça s'est passé il
y a 10 jours lors d'une soirée étudiante
au lycée tiers de Marseille un élève de
classe prépa à relever ce défi de mettre
une souris dans sa bouche et de la
mâcher jusqu'à la mort
un truc de ouf une souris vivant
Leicester mon frère bon bien sûr la
Fondation 30 Millions d'Amis à porter
plainte pour acte de cruauté et
entraîner la mort d'un animal regardez
on va en parler dans un instant regardez
l'extrait c'est un truc de fou bien sûr
on va en parler juste après avec nos
amis c'est parti font froid dans le dos
la Fondation 30 Millions d'Amis a
annoncé porter plainte après la
découverte d'une vidéo tournée lors
d'une soirée d'intégration de la classe
préparatoire du lycée Pierre selon des
témoignages récoltés par l'association
un jeune homme aurait mâché une souris à
la suite d'un pari avec ses camarades
l'animal qui appartenait à une autre
étudiante présente à la soirée était
bien vivant lorsqu'il a été introduit
dans sa bouche
donc là sachez que c'est passé non
flouté sur BFM mais nous comme C8 on est
plus bête que les autres on floute comme
d'habitude ils sont vraiment très très
bêtes dans cette chaîne un étudiant
filmé en train de mâcher une souris
vivant 30 Millions d'Amis portent
plainte qu'est-ce que vous en pensez et
l'étudiant t'apporte pas pleines
la violence et les dégénérer dans les
week-ends
comme à éthylique tous pour la plupart
mais vraiment ils sont drogués
alors on leur fait des brimades des des
sortes de sur le physique comme ça moi
je me souviens quand j'étais en classe
prépa c'était il y a 45 ans mais on
m'avait demandé donc sur la place du
Trocadéro je crois que je l'avais
raconté c'était très très humiliant j'ai
eu vraiment beaucoup de mal à supporter
le truc donc quand j'étais dans un sac
poubelle j'avais donc les mains
attachées derrière et on m'avait demandé
de faire une fellation au statut autour
de la vous avez du Trocadéro on avait
mis de la du de la chantilly sur toutes
les statues du Trocadéro et donc on
passait à tour de rôle comme ça et on
devait enlever la chantilly sur les
sexes des statuts du Trocadéro
Jean-Michel
[Rires]
on a peur de d'être nul d'être traités
voilà et c'était très très humiliant moi
j'ai vécu plutôt pas trop mal mais je
sais que ça peut vraiment blesser des
gens et le pire c'est quand on rajoute
ça l'alcool et la drogue alors là c'est
carrément dramatique voilà alors en fait
il faut pas faire des trucs ou quoi
c'est quoi cette histoire
qu'il fera de la prison ferme je vais
vous dire c'est la souris il reste 50
prisons hein
maintenant c'est très condamné
maintenant c'est très condamné de manger
une souris bah bien sûr vivante bien sûr
un animal domestique même une souris
verte qui courait dans l'herbe
normal
en plus le ça s'est passé dans un cadre
disons périscolaire mais le rectorat a
dit c'est pas nos affaires ils se sont
bandés les yeux
moi j'espère qu'il y aura une enquête et
qui va être condamnée à de la prison
ferme voilà je vous le dis sincèrement
mais c'est parce que c'est un scandale
une personne qui est violée on la
condamne mais les gens et les violeurs
et que les gens qui n'ont forcé attends
en train regarde elle elle a fait on va
pas on va pas la mettre en prison parce
qu'elle a elle a fait elle était sous
pression
oui non tu imagines en prison tu es là
pourquoi
[Rires]
j'ai pris deux anges
il faut pas sous-estimer la contrainte
est-ce qu'il est dans son état normal
est-ce qu'il a eu peur de menace on l'a
tapé pour faire ça tout ça ça se passe
dans les classes préparatoires mais en
droit pénale c'est l'auteur des actes
qui est responsable après il peut y
avoir une une assiette pour d'autres
condamnations mais lui sera condamné
malheureusement c'est toujours à celui
qui fera le truc le plus bête du monde
on a l'impression qu'il y a chaque année
c'est encore plus stupide donc il y a
aussi ça et là où je suis d'accord avec
Monsieur Verdez ce soir ça m'arrivera
pas souvent c'est que j'espère bien non
c'est que franchement encore une fois
l'éducation nationale mais qu'est-ce
qu'ils font le lycée dit rien enfin
c'est on peut pas faire
scolaire je suis désolé c'est des gamins
qui sont lissé tiers il y a une
responsabilité quand même des
enseignants et du corps d'enseignant
mais justement il faut le condamner
est-ce que vous pensez
où il y en a qui disent non mais ça va
les mecs on va pas là en prison
de l'argent il peut ça peut être
déjà le lycée c'est exprimé en déplorant
totalement ce qui s'était passé mais ils
disent que c'était pas dans l'enceinte
de l'établissement et moi je pense qu'il
faudrait plus punir totalement les chefs
de groupe des confréries comme ça qui
organisent leur truc parce que moi ce
mec là j'étais d'accord avec Fabienne je
le vois un peu comme Géraldine victime
du truc alors c'est une victime
complètement débile soit mais il était
aussi alcoolisé il était dans ils ont
voulu le chauffer et je pense que ce mec
là bah s'en est rendu compte après comme
d'habitude on peut déplorer aussi le
fait que ce soit filmé et que ce soit
posté parce que là on pense que c'est
normal mais en fait maintenant tout est
posté tout est filmé et je trouve ça
vraiment
avec la plus grande fermeté et tout ce
qui touche aux animaux de toute façon je
suis hypersensible là ça va ça s'est
passé à Paris il a mangé une souris qui
viennent faire le Marion qui mange un
raté cet hiver
Paris là il fera moins le mariole
Marseille
il a voulu faire une vanne il a loupé
allez merci vraiment vraiment non moi je
pense qu'il faut pas commencer
j'entends prison pour une souris et il a
mangé une souris c'est pas bien et on ne
sait pas s'il a été chauffé comme à
digéradine dans les trucs d'intégration
des cafards ils s'en vont pas mais voilà
c'est pas c'est pas la question bah
c'est pas le déchet du moustique du
cafard de la souris c'est pas bien sûr
on va pas le mettre deux mois non mais
c'est pas que je suis pas humaniste mais
les souris on en fait des expériences
pour nous plus tard là c'est une
connerie c'est une véritable connerie
mais tu dois arriver deux mois à la
prison c'est pas le Club Med les mecs
vous arrivez deux mois en prison tu es
là pourquoi moi j'ai une souris les mecs
c'est une statue et toi tu as fait quoi
[Applaudissements]
même à l'étranger c'est n'importe quoi
on va passer pour des cons même à
l'étranger imagine alors la cellule
c'est un braquage
[Musique]
surtout que pour manger pour manger une
souris alors déjà faut vraiment y aller
avec les crocs et surtout qu'il aurait
pas pu la vallée elle serait resté
coincé il aurait pu mourir enfin un truc
comme ça
j'ai déjà fait du rap sur ma vie j'ai
déjà bouffé du ras sur une île on est
obligé de le couper en quatre pour le
bouffer parce que tu peux pas prendre
quelque chose de vivant surtout une
souris déjà pour la pour la couper en
deux parfois tirer avec la main et pour
la vallée ça ça reste dans la queue
c'est le seul truc qui sort en fait
qui sort
oui j'ai votre réponse sur pourquoi pas
pour un cafard alors que la souris là
elle est considérée comme animal
domestique en captivité ou apprivoiser
parce qu'elle appartenait à une autre
élève voilà c'est pour ça qu'il risque
énormément plus donc 50 prisons il y a
un ami à moi qui m'envoie ceci il a
mangé une souris parce qu'il avait un
chat dans la gorge
[Applaudissements]
oh très drôle très très drôle voilà très
très drôle oui très drôle c'est très
mignon mais c'est très drôle c'est très
très beau tiens peut-il être sanctionné
ces événement sévèrement regardez
75%. non c'est fou